[Music]
hey y'all welcome to the uplift come on
in we got a great show for you today and
a great cast of characters we've got a
high school senior who not only overcame
the long odds to graduate but was able
to walk up and collect his diploma got a
group of teens who risk their own lives
to save their neighbors a dog helping
the people who were used to helping
others a woman with a lot of giant
friends how she changed the lives of
these elephants in need and the artists
behind the drawing that has become the
official I voted sticker for one New
York County all that plus the top
heartwarming videos we think you need to
see this is the uplift
[Music]
welcome to the uplift we call it the
show that lifts you up for at least the
next 30 minutes I'm David begno and we
are going to start with our top
heartwarming videos the first one comes
from a pretty expressive three-year-old
watch this and I'm so precious and I'm
so really happy and super happy
I'm glad you're happy you're glad I'm
happy well daddy is happy
and are you happy too I'm so happy oh
hey a three of you
what a cutie patootie take a look at
this video that shows a pretty sweet
moment between a husband and a wife
thank you
You Ain't Seen Nothing Yet kid
says it all doesn't it that video was
captured by Sarah Kennedy norcoy who
says her mother has vascular dementia
and has been declining steadily for a
few years her dad was also recently
diagnosed with Alzheimer's and Dementia
they've been together for nearly 60
years and her dad still does as much as
he can
the next video shows eight-year-old
Riley who tried out for the softball
team and was waiting to see if she'd
made it watch
will you read this out loud
why okay
we're coming to tryouts
hi Kristen I'm so sorry for the delete
whatever here we would love to have
Riley on the team please let us know if
if she accepts or whatever this offer
just a heads up okay okay okay
[Music]
are you excited
are you so excited Eddie made the team
too
made the team baby girl oh the joy of
that as they say you're never too young
or too old to start a new hobby check
out this Grandpa he proves just that
they call him Papa Rudy and he picked up
baking at 90 years old he's 92 today and
his granddaughter say he bakes them a
cake every time they visit
First Responders dedicate their lives to
helping others and the job as you know
is pretty stressful so who is there to
help them CBS Minnesota Susan Elizabeth
Littlefield has more
it's one of the most important jobs
there is and it's one of the most
stressful too and as of late calls for
help have doubled
I know Crews that have worked upwards of
eight nine calls a day so in health
Fairview EMS made a new hire
this is Clayton the therapy dog his main
purpose is just to kind of to be a dog
and be a cuddly dog that people like to
interact with so that they can
kind of
remove themselves from for at least a
moment and as we were shooting this very
story we watched it play out in real
time after a team got back from a really
tough scene Clayton came to greet them
come visit again walked in I was like oh
I instantly forgot about that call it
was a good mental break before we have
to go back out there and do it all over
again and he's not just good in crisis
he's perfect for company between calls
it's so nice to be able to come in and
take a minute and sit down and just
relax and puddle pop a little serotonin
boost pet a dog and then gets you better
prepared to go out and help other people
when you're filling your cup with some
puppy cuddles it's great Clayton is
trained on command including the command
it's a snuggle snuggle
Kevin Kane is an EMS supervisor and
Clayton's new housemate he's the perfect
mix of black goofy but attentive
attentive to the needs of those who tend
to the needs of others he helps us help
people better too that's good for
everybody
let me tell you that is no joke so I
didn't grow up with dogs and I kind of
wouldn't have understood a story like
that until I finally got a dog and I'm
telling you he's my pride and joy and I
tell people my blood pressure literally
drops when I'm around my dog if you
don't have one I advise you try it
coming up meet the teens who risk their
own lives to save their neighbors what
did they do we'll tell you right after
the break plus another teenager who
faced a major health challenge but
overcame it at graduation to walk at his
graduation
so our next story is about a teenager
who was determined to graduate from high
school even though he faced a lot of
challenges Caitlin O'Kane talked to him
about how he overcame the odds to get
his diploma
imagine being a regular high school
student you're almost 16 you get your
first job and then you're diagnosed with
a brain tumor that's what happened to
Christian Mendoza he faced multiple
near-death moments was hospitalized for
months and underwent more than 20
surgeries at Akron Children's Hospital
the parents worst nightmare
it's not something that you can't ever
wants to hear you basically have he had
to reconnect his brain and his body so
not only did he have to relearn how to
walk for graduation he had to relearn
how to talk he couldn't talk for months
and months he had to relearn how to eat
he had to relearn how to pick up his
phone how to
every movement that your body makes he
had to relearn to do that
despite all the obstacles Christian was
determined to finish High School
he played ketchup and he did all of his
studies virtually
um this kid that's had 20 selfie brain
tumors
had an a in a virtual geometry I mean
so smart
so smart he not only completed all of
his coursework he had hours of therapy a
day to relearn how to walk with one goal
in mind
the white third graduation dollars
why didn't they give myself
that was just something I wanted to
and when that day came Christian reached
his goal walking to receive his high
school diploma
[Applause]
[Music]
by God's life
it's my big moment I need to get through
it next up Christian hopes to go to
college and study psychology so he can
one day help people just like himself
[Music]
Christian we love you buddy that is a
great story thanks to Caitlyn for that
our next story is about a group of
California teenagers who risk their own
lives to save their neighbors CBS
Sacramento's Marley gitner has the story
out of a burning home the little girl
yeah and then the other kid in the back
that's seven seven eight when Jesus
better known as Chewie to his buddies
saw smoke at a neighbor's house he ran
to make sure everyone was all right we
started we started banging we started we
started being on the doors we started
throwing rocks to the windows to see the
wake up when that wasn't enough he
kicked down the door I saw a little kid
so I took him to the front I give them
to someone to carry them and then I went
back Chewie's sister caught all the
chaos on camera in my voice in the video
you can hear like it's already cracking
because I wanted to cry I was
what about you Pedro were you scared
I mean kinda but once I seen Chewie come
out I was like I'ma just go in there
with them so if anything happens to him
I could get him out
sounds like you all had each other's
backs yeah basically they did something
really really amazing
yeah way to go mom when you were
watching the video though did you get a
little nervous I did I did I was scared
because I'm hearing truly sisters you
know screaming and I'm like oh my God
what's going on you know that that fear
of a pairing you know like you want to
protect your children that instinct
clearly passed down to these boys who
never hesitated to save complete
strangers from a burning house the right
thing to do you know like like it's like
basically put it in your shoes like if
your house is burning what would you
like someone to help you or not like
like that you know like I would I would
appreciate if someone came and helped me
if my house is running down
it's that human instinct to help others
we've all got it and when you see others
doing it young or old it's infectious
isn't it coming up what's behind the
meaning of a pretty wacky drawing that
won a contest to become the official I
voted sticker plus a woman dedicated to
rescuing elephants how she convinced
other people to help give them the love
that they deserve we're back in a moment
[Music]
thank you
welcome back when a U.S marine without
any close relatives recently died his
Wisconsin Community proved he did have
family
CBS Minnesota's Jennifer mayerly has
that story
they all came I thought mileage doesn't
matter you know it's just honoring a
fellow Soldier for the same reason
humbling very humbling to see so many
people for a gentleman that did not have
the family U.S marine gail seafloth
given a full military funeral and burial
neighbor Holly Champaign says he was
special to her family is this the big
Gruff
grumpy tall
tall man who
was just super nice if you got
underneath that exterior the Vietnam
veteran died in January and when the
friend who was to care for his ashes
also died the county Veterans Services
office planned a burial they invited
everyone via social media to thank the
76 year old for his commitment to
Country and to honor his life in the
last five years I've done this four
times now for veterans who didn't have
family so it's to bring awareness that
if it's going to happen here in small
Barron County it's happening all over
the United States Patriot Guard and
Legion Riders veterans civilians
strangers all wanted to pay their
respects he's a veteran I'm a veteran so
there's sort of a kinship even though I
never knew the man it's a touching
situation to honor this veteran people
who came who were here to honor Gail
tell me he will always have family he
deserves every bit of this he didn't
think he did but he deserves that every
bit of this
the kindness of strangers
our next story is about aspiring
Lifesavers so there's a camp in
Minnesota that is dedicated to teaching
young people how to be First Responders
here CBS Minnesota's Susan Elizabeth
Littlefield
[Music]
um the CPR or like helping people so I
was really interested in that and then
they first talked about it is intrigued
as well but liked the most
[Music]
probably seen the fire truck shoot the
um waterer the students learned about
fire rescues and now they're learning
about the heaviness of water rescues I'm
really one of like them saving people or
like finding like retrieving bodies like
so it would like help families feel much
easier or better the camp is funded by
donations from people like Steve all of
us at one time in our life almost all of
us
have eaten at a smorgasbord this gives
them an opportunity to taste a little of
this and a little of that and a little
of this and hopefully they'll bite into
the right the right product and and step
forward in a career path and they are
moving forward whether by land or lake
with bravery and humility even though
it's really what do you call it
um physically probably physically tough
I'd I'd be willing to take the Rhythm
I can see you as a hero thank you
I'm not in here but
when we come back meet the founder of
Thailand's oldest elephant sanctuary and
the gentle Giants that she cares for
plus how will this unlikely drawing be
used to promote voter turnout and what
the heck inspired It Anyway hear from
the 14 year old artist who created it
right after the break
[Music]
so when the pandemic hit a lot of us
stayed inside without any visitors right
well some elephants in Thailand can
relate but there's one woman who's
making sure those elephants in need get
all the love they deserve
a lady we love Elizabeth Palmer went
there to get the story
he would take me let Tyler loves
elephants I'm sorry about that she's a
big boss here and they love her right
back
[Music]
she's the founder of Thailand's oldest
elephant Sanctuary
what's she saying do you know I don't
know
before covid it was a magnet for foreign
tourists who paid to see these animals
roaming free
but the pandemic wiped out both tourism
and the money it brought in
for two years the only visitors have
been a few volunteers like AJ Hill from
California
determined to help childert sanctuary as
a Humane alternative to cruel elephant
circuses the way that they have to train
the elephants is they they like abuse
them they sort of they put nails in
their ears and they chained them up so
they can't move anywhere it's just
upsetting
childhood's animals are all elderly
formally abused or unwell so looking
after them is expensive she's got cancer
yes
covid dealt a double whammy to lack
suddenly she was dealing with a lot less
money and many more mouths to feed
30 extra animals were dropped off here
during the pandemic by owners who could
no longer afford them
they just left them here they just left
them here yes so Tyler added them to the
family and made sure somehow that the
food wouldn't run short
in the kitchen it's all hands on deck
right down to the littlest the sanctuary
grew some of its own food
more came from local farmers and upward
of a million dollars rolled in from
donors especially in the United States
covet has has been a disaster in many
ways but you said for you it's brought
something good yeah Kobe had bought also
positive to Elephant living in Thailand
[Music]
specifically it brought a lull in Mass
elephant tourism
and Childers spotted an opportunity
on the property next door
elephants used to perform for up to 2
000 tourists a day
but when the tour buses stopped coming
and the elephant riding saddle sat idle
chylert convinced the owners to take off
the chains and turn this place into a
sanctuary too when we visited Tom the
vet was dodging a very protective mom
to dab ointment on her two-day-old baby
he may not grow up in the wild but
thanks to lechiler none of these animals
will have to do tricks in a circus
like her own elephants they'll be free
to roam in a protected home
I don't know if you believe in heaven
but if you do there's a place there for
her
you know those I voted stickers that we
get on Election Day all the time well
one County in New York state has a brand
new design and when you see it you might
not believe it's really official Caitlin
O'Kane spoke to the artist behind the
now legendary design
when you think of stickers you get for
voting on Election Day you may picture a
patriotic design that reads I voted
Ulster County New York wanted to
reimagine those stickers so they held a
design contest
six stickers were chosen as finalists
there's an American bald eagle red white
and blue motifs and then there's this 14
year old Hudson Rowan is The Mastermind
behind the design it was his mom who
told him he should enter the contest
once you told me about it I wasn't
totally like psyched in the idea I
didn't really and it wasn't really my
thing and then she encouraged me so I
was like sure I'll try it
Hudson's unconventional I voted sticker
took off with about 93 of the vote Yes
you heard that right Hudson steadily had
a majority of the votes but what is the
inspiration for the sticker
oh that's a good question
um I always get asked that and I don't
really know like
I don't
I've always been doing like those types
of drawings
so I guess it like the kind of like
jagged lines crazy spider like drawings
so I think that kind of just influenced
it because when I was little I used to
paint a lot and I used to paint these
things I would call them
spider robots which was just like a
circle with legs but when you look at
the I voted sticker it looks like
the spider robot that I used to make
when I was little he couldn't have
imagined the sensation it would become I
don't think I'd think of it I thought if
I submit this my mom will stop asking me
to submit it so I submitted it and then
left it alone and then Mom told me like
a little bit later Hudson you have
thousands of um votes thousands turned
to twenty thousand then two hundred
thousand and here I am with two hundred
and twenty thousand votes and it's
insane like how fast that happens
there's only about 178
000 people in Ulster County so many more
outside the area casted their vote for
Hudson and he hopes the sticker
encourages people to cast votes again in
the election seeing it and how much
attention is brought to I hope that also
brings attention to voting and will
influence people to vote to cast their
vote and also to get the sticker
he didn't go into this thinking his
original design would make a big impact
but that spider robot has become
legendary I feel like because it's so
different from what you'd expect when
you think of a sticker like that but
you're scrolling down and you're seeing
like eagles and like red white and blue
and stuff and as you scrolling down all
sudden you see this thing boom like
spider creature crazy head and it very
stands out and it catches eye and I know
if like I was looking at something
contest like that I would see that and
I'd be like oh these are cool bam that's
the one I want I want to wear that
foreign
take it from Hudson be unconventional be
yourself be different stand out it works
trust me and that is our show I hope
this news brighten your day lifted you
up maybe sure did for me I'm David begno
this is the uplift make it a good one